northern nevada congressman mark amade  recently spoke on vaccine distribution  and funding for distribution for the  program eggs and issues take a listen  we just got some more information from  the folks at cdc  and also the state folks in terms of  about 60 days ago  cdc provided i think it was a billion  eight or something like that  to the state of nevada in terms of to  set up distribution  uh infrastructure for when that comes  it's being distributed right now  on a per capita basis so i don't have  the number of what that is  per person we expect 70 75 percent of  those funds  to go to the clark county health  district and and go through that  in terms of getting ready  he also said that operation warp speed  helped equip our state with needles and  other necessary equipment when the first  round of vaccine doses  is given david